[Music]
morning everybody after 20 years
afghanistan is once again under taliban
rule after the group seized kabul and
effectively took control of the country
militants moved into the capital
yesterday sparking chaos with roads
gridlocked and thousands of people
attempting to flee
this was the scene at kabul airport in
the last few hours where people have
been desperately trying to get on board
an aircraft all commercial flights have
been suspended
the u.s official says troops trying to
secure the airport have fired shots in
the air to try to prevent hundreds of
people from running onto the tarmac
the official described the crowd as out
of control
these are the scenes on the streets of
kabul with the taliban manning makeshift
security checkpoints halting traffic and
checking inside vehicles
last night taliban fighters entered the
presidential palace after the president
ghani fled the country the taliban says
it promises an open inclusive islamic
government for afghanistan
let's speak to the defense secretary ben
wallace joining us now hello to you mr
wallace thank you for joining us on the
programme as you did
last friday morning um
talk to me if you would as the uk's
defense secretary how did you feel as
you witnessed the scenes um
yesterday in kabul
through strategic patience the taliban
has won this war
well i think you know as i
both spoke to you last week and indeed
in the
article i wrote for started telegraph
look i i think we all saw that and felt
a a real sense of sadness uh that
uh first of all the forces that the
british and the international community
had invested in had melted away in some
areas so quickly i i think it was always
the lessons that you know i felt
incredibly important is that you you
don't fix things overnight in in global
issues you have to
manage them and you know ultimately as
i've said a number of times publicly
when when that deal was done a few years
ago what happened was ultimately we
undermined
you know the the community the the deal
undermined the afghan government and
left it in a place that ultimately saw
the end and the end is always
i'm afraid you know the river flows
faster towards the end and that that is
what we saw yesterday and it's what
we're seeing in our pictures today but
you know my job as defense secretary is
to make sure that we protect
not only the uk nationals but those
afghans they have an obligation to that
is actually why we're in the country the
last few weeks we've been in the country
solely to process those people
and to make sure we protect
our officials doing that job and we'll
continue to do so so you acknowledge
that the taliban has won the war
i don't have a win i think i acknowledge
that the taliban are in control of the
country i mean you don't have to be a
political scientist to spot that to
where we're at
and you know i have engaged through a
third country yesterday to make sure we
seek assurances from the taliban to
protect our people and indeed the people
we're trying to work to get out
and you don't have to be a political
scientist to figure out whether or not
nato can regroup and go back to take
over kabul again i'm guessing at this
stage that's not on the cuts
no i look that's not on the cards that
we're going to go back if you remember
at his height over 100 000 troops were
deployed
into afghanistan to hold the line that
wasn't just the initial obviously 2001
2002 intervention that was you know
almost a decade later uh heavy heavy
fighting
and i think uh you know the united
states has made itself clear that
they're not intending uh to stay and as
the framework nation uh that leaves us
with difficult choices and you know i've
been
pretty much honest about that all the
way through this process and actually
why as i said our defense strategy and
our defense reform program that we put
in place back in march is designed so
that we're no longer so dependent on one
power or the other it's why we are a
record funding settlement so that in
future should something like this happen
again we can find it easier to find
international partners to to remain
okay okay we are where we are um you're
drawing up plans for an airlift britain
is set to evacuate its citizens um talk
to me about the logistics as best you
can how many people are we talking about
how long is it going to take and when
will it start
so it started already uh only yesterday
uh nearly 300 people came back uh we
i've just been like you seeing the
footage of the airport that's been going
on at the moment uh the military side of
the airport so the footage you're seeing
is from the south side the civilian side
the military side of the airport is
secure
and controlled and military flights are
coming in and out and i think on friday
when i spoke to you i told you we had a
plan b which was if civilian flights
stop we will use military flights that
is what we're doing the military flights
are coming in and out they've just
brought in more uk soldiers
border force is joining us to make sure
that we accelerate the process to get
more afghans out which is our obligation
we we flew out
370 staff
and british citizens eligible personnel
yesterday and the day before and we'll
continue to engage those flights uh the
next group of afghans to come out will
be 782
and we'll make sure we get them in the
next 24 to 36 hours out of the country
and i'll continue to process those
people how many emergency visas can we
process for those who risk their lives
for the uk in the time that's left
well we've processed over 2 000 plus
since april with their families and
they're all back in the uk located with
their families and myself in the home
secretary i spoke to her all through
yesterday and i'll continue to speak to
her today we are processing as fast as
we can and where there are sort of
rules that we need to change we are
changing those rules and so today i'll
be speaking to pretty patel about how we
can deal with afghan passports right up
until day before yesterday the afghans
wouldn't let afghans leave without their
passport
if if they've already been through our
checks we know who they are we need to
see if we can uh make sure that we adapt
the rules to get those people out as
soon as we can and we will cycle them
out from afghanistan to a middle east
country and then back to the united
kingdom so we can keep the flow of
airplanes in and out and
our our target is at least 15 about 1200
to 1500 exit a day in the capacity of
our airplanes
and we'll keep that flowing and we've
secured a place
within the airport that we can process
people securely and then marshal them
onto the planes 2000 is not enough there
is as far as the interpreters are
concerned are we are we processing many
more than that at the moment given the
situation that is developing and
some have already been killed others
surely will be
yeah so
first of all it's not just interpreters
it's it's public facing roles and any
even essential non-public function roles
it's also contractors uh we again a few
weeks ago pretty good and i changed the
rules to make sure third-party
contractors were able to come through
because that was important and then also
third country processing there are there
are a significant number who've got
themselves out of
afghanistan over the last few weeks and
they are in camps at refugee camps
around the world we brought a guy back
in april as long as from
family from a greek refugee camp we're
going to be processing them wherever
they are and we're going to continue to
do that after we've gone but but you
know you're right kay it's really
important for us these are people
you know i've been as blunt as i can
saying that we will do everything we can
to bring as many people out as possible
and our soldiers that the 600 we've
flown in from 16 air assault brigade
they are on the ground specifically and
for only one job which is the processing
of british citizens and afghans to bring
them back we're not there for any other
government function that's what what
those men and women are now risking
their lives to do and quite rightly so
that is our obligation and we will do
that for as long as we can
yeah um the taliban has other ideas the
spokesperson suhil shaheen
saying we need all afghans to stay we're
saying
we need those that are fought side by
side with us or represented us in some
other way can come back to the uk
that sounds like a bit of a standoff how
are we going to fix that
well i i spoke to a middle east country
yesterday who contacted the taliban
on my behalf the military leadership of
the taliban to seek assurances and uh
the assurance i got back from that
leadership was that these people would
not be uh interfered with and that
they wanted to demonstrate that people
could come and go to afghanistan as
freely as possible and and that have
also you know that they obviously want
western troops out of their country so
it's not in their interest to
impede all of that and we will make sure
that we continue to do that
um last time the taliban was in charge
41 000 people sought asylum in the
united kingdom from afghanistan how many
asylum seekers are we expecting this
time
i i don't know but i suspect we will see
significant migrant plays around the
world um you know i i
you know my turkish counterpart is
dealing with significant
inflows i know that the iranians
historically usually take huge amounts
of refugees pakistan india
as well and and i think you know it
it's not a comfort to this situation but
back in march when we did our defense
reform paper you know i recognize that
conflict prevention
and post-conflict uh work is as
important as war fighting because the
the threat to our stability from migrant
flows organized crime smuggling
terrorism is very very important we have
to be out around the world to deliver
that stability and so
we can expect at least as many this time
can't we well i'm not going to put a
figure on it
if the taliban are true to the words
that you've also read out on your
program about
an inclusive islamic state but
nevertheless
well i i certainly think they will not
miss the lesson of 2011 that uh hosting
terrorists and indeed uh running a state
as they did led to rampant poverty uh
migration immigration or refugee crises
and indeed the toppling of that regime
those those are facts that happen 20
years ago
and certainly the political uh
leadership of the taliban recognized
that so
you know
on that sense the onus is on on them to
do that and so in the meantime i am
focused about getting those people out
there's brits out there's afghans out
and actually working together with our
allies you know whether it's turkey or
whether it's qatar or whether it's other
middle east countries uh to make sure
that we help stabilize the situation
um yeah i we are already hearing of
executions of those who worked with the
nato forces women literally being turned
away from their places of learning
it doesn't look um anecdotally as though
the taliban has changed much
lately no that it does not look like a
change um and i think uh we have to make
sure that the taliban leadership lead
their country and uh you know if there
are
provinces or groups that are behaving
like that
you know that both the european union
the united uh kingdom and the usa have
been very clear that you know the
leadership has a responsibility uh to
make sure that it upholds human rights
uh as does the quran actually the the
quran does not uh uh accept many of
these things um and that is a wrongful
interpretation of the quran so i think i
think that it's really really important
that the taliban recognize they're on
display now the international community
is watching they want the finances they
want the flow of money they want the aid
they want to be accepted
as a
national leadership then they're going
to have to deliver that
how prepared are you for the taliban
flag to be flying over the uk embassy in
kabul
well uh look that's the consequence of
the taliban it's not the embassy anymore
we have left that location we've drawn
down within the airport as have a member
of other nations many of the eu have
relocated so it's now just a building uh
but uh you know
in the end of the day
yeah
symbolically uh it's not what any of us
wanted
okay will you recognize the taliban as
the government of afghanistan
i think there is a lot of more to come
before those decisions are made i think
i think the taliban have to match their
words with what they say i think the
time is not right yet uh the proof of
the pudding will be obviously in their
actions rather than their rhetoric okay
how frustrated were you that the foreign
secretary was on holiday abroad when all
this was unfolding
genuinely i don't know where he was or
as in whether it was cyprus i believe
okay i i don't know his uh my colleagues
personal movements what i do know is
every single day i spoke to foreign
secretary every day i had no problems
nor did the prime minister or anyone
else engaging with the foreign office
the foreign office has been in lockstep
with the mod who have been at the
forefront of delivering this alongside
the home office so uh you know i have
not been aware of any drop in service or
inability to deliver the whole of
government has been tasked on this the
prime minister uh convened his first
cobra a few days ago and a second one
yesterday and we're all determined to
deliver the solution
can we end where we started please the
taliban are not known to be patient
except potentially uh these last two
decades when they wanted to take back
their country they certainly seem to
have managed that over the last 24 hours
they won't
take too long before they decide that
they want the airport back we have a
finite amount of time to get brits and
those who help the brits out what's your
time scale
well our declared timestar was by the
end of the month and the first week of
september but recognizing exactly what
you say
we are doing everything and we'll be
doing it today to remove any further
barriers to make sure we can rush
through both afghans and british
citizens
to make sure that we can process them
and get out of the country as soon as
possible by the end of the month
well that was our original timetable and
but i recognize as the facts on the
ground change okay we have to change too
which is why the home sector and i have
been working absolutely and hand in hand
in the last few weeks to make sure we
remove those barriers the prime minister
the chancellor be incredibly supportive
in delivering that
and we will move on we have to move
about move regulations today we'll be
doing exactly that
thank you for joining us defense
secretary
thank you
so it's a race against time isn't it the
streets of kabul virtually deserted
today with government offices embassies
and shops all closed the taliban says
its fighters have been ordered to allow
civilians to go about their daily lives
but it's clear the city and afghanistan
as a whole has woken up to a new future
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey is
in kabul and watched as the taliban
entered afghanistan's capital
we'd been warned but this was the first
time that we realized something was
happening gunfire followed by people
running
police vehicles suddenly appearing on
the streets that were emptying fast
within minutes helicopter gunships
appeared over the presidential palace
and government buildings in the center
of kabul
anti-missile systems firing chaff into
the air
the taliban had entered the city and the
american pilots knew it
for hours they circled above but there
was nothing they could do to stop the
takeover of the capital
occasional gunfire ripped through the
air
throughout the day chinook helicopters
fed united states embassy staff to the
international airport
road moves deemed far too dangerous
it hart back to the images of the
ignominious retreat of the us from
vietnam
an image president biden said wouldn't
be repeated
but this still photograph may well come
back to haunt the president in the days
to come
in kabul crowds gathered to welcome the
taliban they greeted speakers with
enthusiasm
inside the presidential palace they
rammed home this remarkable takeover
posing in the offices of power
a power that after two decades of trying
has failed to finish them
the tension in kabul has been a bursting
point as we left our hotel to see what
was going on the taliban were right in
front of us
they stared but let us pass
it won't be like this for long
these streets are usually heaving with
people and cars they were deserted
traffic jams are a permanent fixture
here the reason army and police
checkpoints
now though we pass through unimpeded
these heavily armed mini fortresses now
unmanned
once again the afghan soldiers have
melted away
in just a
very short while after the arrival of
the taliban and
news that spread through the city the
streets are really empty i mean we were
here uh uh only
a day or so ago and in the hours from
this morning we could see it was
absolutely
shock about with people
now uh
it's uh it's it's pretty quiet
pretty empty a lot of people have just
gone home
there's no real sort of
authority on the streets anymore
this population knows what's coming some
of the changes are subtle no jeans and
t-shirts now they've changed into
traditional xiaowa kameez clothing and
there's no women to be seen
and no images of women on beauty salon
windows either
whitewash
the president's words of security infer
order at the airport there wasn't much
of that to be seen
there's a mad scramble to get on flights
that have been cancelled and on to
military flights to which there's no
access
the roads clogged with traffic and
afghan military vehicles
moving in all directions but mainly away
from the taliban
on the roadside the latest arrivals from
battles around the country drag their
belongings along the dusty roads looking
for somewhere to stay
none will forget the day the taliban
returned
their 20-year war
is won stuart ramsey sky news kabul
joined now by middle east correspondent
alistair bunkel who is standing by
alastair uh good morning to you
interesting uh conversation there with
the defense secretary a few moments ago
um reflecting on how distasteful it will
be symbolically to see the afghan the
taliban flag flying over the what was
british embassy and also the airlift
speeding up
well i think i have to accept now that
images like the taliban the white
taliban flag flying over locations like
the british embassy the u.s embassy the
presidential palace and central kabul uh
is is fair to complete the taliban have
declared the war over and uh there is no
denying that they have won a 20-year
struggle
and very quickly indeed a matter of days
really to sweep across the country in a
stunning blitzkrieg that
took most people by a surprise although
some u.s intelligence analysts
i read
said that they had forewarned the white
house that this might happen
but their warnings were not heeded and
so uh afghanistan this morning is waking
up to a new power base it is the same
power base that existed in the country
20 years ago but will it have a
different philosophy will it have a
different strategy for governing country
or will it be the same old taliban that
governs in a very strict
religious manner and diminishes the
rights and freedoms particularly of
women in the country that is the great
fear and i don't think there's an awful
lot the international community can do
about it uh if that is the way it goes
for now the immediate priority of the
international communities you spoke to
with ben wallace is to get uh both
britons and uh any uh afghans who have
helped the british effort over the last
20 years out of the country
it won't be straightforward they're
looking at lifting anywhere between 1200
and 1500 a day
uh but we've been seeing those scenes
from the airport this morning it is
utterly chaotic it is desperate and it
is extremely sad actually
uh as you watch uh so many hundreds and
thousands of afghans trying to climb on
board aircraft like that do anything
they can do to try and leave the country
with no signs
of help
to do that that is i should say uh the
civilian side of the airport it's a big
airport uh hamid karzai international
airport and on the other side the
northern end uh pretty much as you're
looking down uh that is the military
side so this does not necessarily affect
the scene on the ground uh where the
british and the americans have it a
little bit more under control but what
it does reflect is the fear in the
country
and the desperation not to live under
the rule of the taliban and one final
thing okay that i would pick up um from
the interview uh that you've just
conducted with ben wallace is the
potential for terrorist groups to harbor
themselves uh in afghanistan once again
of course
9 11 was the reason uh the forces went
in to get rid of al-qaeda well i was
with the afghan national security
advisor now the former national security
adviser only a couple of weeks ago
he did not see this coming but what he
did say is that he saw elements of
al-qaeda within the taliban and he made
the point that extremist groups don't
operate in silos okay for now aleister
thank you
still to come on the programme for you
what responsibility does the united
states have for the taliban's takeover
i'm going to be talking to a former uk
ambassador to the us at quarter to eight
and at quarter to nine we'll get the
reaction of sir nicholas k he's the
former uk ambassador to afghanistan who
was stationed in kabul just two years
ago
and then at half first nine we'll speak
to lord richard dana former head of the
british army about britain's role in the
conflict
[Music]
the u.s is reportedly sending another
thousand troops to afghanistan and says
it's secured the airport to the northern
end but there's been no word from
president biden who's facing the most
serious test of his presidency so far
our u.s correspondent mark stone joining
us this morning um hello to mark live
from washington uh where is the
president
he is at camp david k uh his uh country
retreat the presidential country retreat
he's been there through the weekend and
there are growing calls this morning for
him to to get back here to get back to
washington to the white house and to
address the nation his schedule at the
moment says he won't do that he will
remain at camp david the only site of
him we've had over the course of the
weekend is a couple of still images
showing him
cutting rather a lonely figure sitting
in a briefing room at camp david with
that screen there
receiving what we are told our regular
updates in terms of what we can expect
today
we may hear from president biden but
it's not been confirmed yet we will hear
from the state department uh this
evening your time uh there will be a
briefing from ned price this uh state
department spokesman or maybe even from
tony blinken the secretary of state
we're not expecting an update from the
pentagon up in new york there will be a
a meeting of the un security council so
expect something out of that i think
there are some urgent
well clearly many many challenges and
many implications from from what what is
an all-american decision let's remember
that this was this is on joe biden he
inherited a deal a so-called peace deal
from his predecessor donald trump but he
made the decision to follow through with
it and to pull troops out there are
immediate implications and we're seeing
them unfold on the tarmac at kabul
international airport right now and then
there are the longer term implications
what does this say about america what
does it say about how western countries
can rely on america you heard ben
wallace there talking about
america being the framework on which
nato stands if america doesn't do
something it is now clear nato cannot
follow through without america what does
it mean for afghanistan we just don't
know at the moment so plenty of
unanswered questions and there is also
okay the domestic politics one of the
key reasons why joe biden followed
through and decided to end this to pull
the troops out
is because
he knows that it plays well domestically
he knows that his predecessor donald
trump said he would do the same thing of
course predictably donald trump is now
saying oh i wouldn't have done it this
way i'd have done it very differently
and is calling for joe biden to resign
you might say he would say that but
domestically this makes things very very
difficult for joe biden and
internationally this as you say is a
huge huge challenge perhaps the issue
that will define his presidency okay for
now thanks mark
afghan officials say the uh president
former president perhaps ashraf ghani
fled the country as the taliban moved
further into kabul let's bring in our
moscow correspondent diana magnay who's
standing by for us this morning um there
were some thoughts about where he was
originally potentially not in that
country anymore what do we know diana
good morning
good morning kay it is unclear where
he's gone president our former president
ashraf ghani left a message on
facebook saying that he fled the country
to avoid further bloodshed
and clashes in the capital kabul and
there were reports that he'd gone
initially to tajikistan
then reports that he hadn't gone there
had gone to uzbekistan and the latest
that i've seen on russian wires is a
source telling interfax that there were
no requests for his plane to land in the
uzbek capital tashkent um
and that source saying he wasn't there
either so it is very unclear where he is
and of course i would imagine that he
doesn't really want people to know where
he is especially in these very early
days especially with the reaction of
quite a few i would imagine back in
afghanistan feeling that he has fled to
safety and left his people
high and dry essentially to face the
taliban on their own
now
russia
uh has called for uh the u.n security
council to meet um this afternoon
alongside a host of other countries
russia has always had fairly lukewarm
relations with president ashraf ghani
but what it has tried to do in
afghanistan is to maintain
talks really with all uh parties so it
has despite calling the taliban an
extremist organization that's banned in
russia
here in moscow since 2018 um and tried
to receive security assurances from them
and that seems to have paid off where
we've seen the uk and the embassies
shuttered uh russia says that it has
received assurances security assurances
from the taliban um and its operations
there continue what russia is most
concerned about is instability from
afghanistan rippling out it won't trust
the taliban's assurances but it has kay
tried to bolster the borders and its
military operations alongside
uzbekistan and tajikistan especially
okay diana for now thanks so much indeed
thank you
this is a live image from downtown kabul
this morning
and
you can see it looks very quiet there at
the moment um
is it the calm before the storm has it
been the peaceful transition that the
taliban is telling us about very
different images at the airport
particularly to the domestic side of the
airport i can tell you that our man in
afghanistan along with his staff are
still there although 300 you can see
this this is the domestic side of the
airport to the north of the airport is
where the military part of the um
airport is and it seems to be much
calmer up there already uh 300 brits are
already back in the uk we heard from ben
wallace who said 700 afghans hopefully
flown out in the next 24 hours or
thereabouts
and the brits are aiming to fly out
between 1200 and 1500 people per day
between now and when the taliban
finally decides that they want all
foreigners out of kabul we will continue
to monitor events for you meantime let's
find out what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned here this morning
nas is standing by hi nas good morning
good morning good morning it's looking
less unsettled for this week is that low
pressure that we had hanging around over
the weekend has shifted away further
eastwards but it is going to be feeling
cooler than recently as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we had a weak area of low
pressure hanging around over the weekend
it's now shifted away eastwards and
we're seeing high pressure building from
the west but as it's still nearby we've
got more of a northerly flow developing
so although it's less unsettled this
week it is going to be feeling cool for
the time of year competitor recently as
well fine for most places this morning a
few showers scattered across the north
of wales and northwest england and
northern and eastern areas and some of
those showers will carry on into this
afternoon too there will be quite a bit
of cloud around particularly across
central southern and western parts of
the uk and ireland but there will be
some breaks in the cloud allowing for
some bright spells the best of the
sunshine across the north and east of
the uk but then later we will be seeing
its smells of heavy rain spreading to
western scotland to parts of the north
of northern ireland and the north of the
republic it is also going to be rather a
breezy cool day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
many thousands of brits and those that
worked with the uk armed forces in
afghanistan are struggling to get out of
afghanistan as quickly as possible
a third country to start with probably
in the middle east then heading to raf
bryce norton uh british troops set off
from there to help uk nationals they'll
be heading back there as well along with
afghans and brits that have managed to
get out of the country where they're
live in just a moment
[Music]
uh the number of casualties of the white
fires declared on monday rose on
wednesday to 69
including more than 20 soldiers fighting
the fire uh we deplore 600 families who
have been homeless and more than one
thousand injured
the algerian red cross and volunteers
are
bringing sanitary assistance and first
aid to the benefit of the first the five
victims
there's also distribution of food and
water brought by a valentine's division
team moreover a carbon consisting on six
ambulances specialized doctors
parapharmaceutical products humanitarian
donation is being sent to assist the
victim of the fires
all the rescued uh family have been
taken in charge so rescue shelters have
been settled up and children
psychological support have been
organized since the beginning of the
fires
and
on the international level the algerian
red crescent has launched an appeal to
strengthen its humanitarian assistance
to its partners within the international
humanitarian movement
we
have
launched an appeal and i we count on the
international solidarity of
red cross and red crescent movements and
then our partners
and of course the solidarity of the
algerian citizens
and of course also the algerian
authorities
we are offering
uh
shelters we are offering food and water
uh
we also
distribute
uh
masks uh gloves because of this pandemic
and
we are trying to relieve people who are
in need
not only design but biology to create
new materials which actually are fully
sustainable and biodegradable
because of provide there was a mass
increase of single-use plastics being
discarded so
for me it seemed like a great
opportunity to have a material which
didn't have a longevity of plastic but
could degrade back into the earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again everybody the defense
secretary has said it is with great
sadness that we've watched afghan
defense forces fall to the taliban so
quickly speaking to us a short time ago
he said the deal that the u.s struck
with the taliban last february was
naive i think we all saw that and felt a
a real sense of sadness uh that
uh first of all the forces that the
british and the international community
had invested in had melted away in some
areas so quickly i i think it was always
the lessons that you know i felt
incredibly important is that you you
don't fix things overnight in in global
issues you have to
uh manage them and uh you know
ultimately as i've said a number of
times publicly when when that deal was
done a few years ago what happened was
ultimately we undermined
you know the the community
the deal undermined the afghan
government and left it in a place that
ultimately saw the end and the end is
always
i'm afraid you know the river flows
faster towards the end and that that is
what we saw yesterday and it's what
we're seeing in our pictures today
tomorrow's with us thoughts tomorrow
well just to dwell on that for a second
he says afghanistan is now in the hands
of the taliban our embassy is no longer
our embassy we're trying to get british
nationals and the afghans who helped us
to the airport and out of the country
and it's clear that over the next couple
of days the focus is going to be on
making sure that evacuation happens it's
a race against the clock as he was
suggesting there
ben wallace said he had engaged with the
taliban actually via a third country to
try and ensure that our citizens will
get out safely but it's very
unpredictable as we saw with those
scenes at the airport he said the goal
is to get 1200 to 1500 people that's
brits afghans embassy personnel out a
day so it should be concluded in a
matter of days but it's going to be a
very fraught time as that is underway
and while um there are around 4 000
british citizens and 2 000 afghans
already processed there are potentially
thousands more afghans who will be
clamoring to try and get a place on one
of those planes people who helped us
during the conflict and say that their
lives are at risk or that they will have
already been targeted since the taliban
began their takeover so a fraught few
days and then of course we've got the
recall of parliament on wednesday we're
one of the key questions will be how did
we fail to foresee this happening and
also what role will britain play in
trying to prevent it becoming a
humanitarian catastrophe how many
refugees might we take how we work with
other countries to try and prevent it as
boris johnson put yesterday again
becoming a haven for terrorism okay for
now tomorrow thank you
meantime the defense secretary also gave
us an update on the airlift operation as
british troops tried to help uk
nationals and afghans out of kabul
the military side of the airport so the
footage you're seeing is from the south
side the civilian side the military side
of the airport is secure
and controlled and military flights are
coming in and out and i think on friday
when i spoke to i told you we had a plan
b which was if civilian flights stop we
will use military flights that is what
we're doing the military flights are
coming in and out they've just brought
in more uk soldiers
border forces joining us to make sure
that we accelerate the process to get
more afghans out
well aisha is at rif bryce norton for us
this morning hello to you good morning
we
know that that's where the military
personnel set off from to head to
afghanistan
we don't know when they'll be bringing
everybody home yet
yep that's right so 600 troops were
deployed from here they arrived in kabul
yesterday and the operation is well
underway to get british nationals back
as well as afghans who've helped the
british forces during this time in fear
that they could be
face reprisals from the taliban if they
don't come back now in the early hours
we did see an raf voyager uh land back
here at bryson norton it's not been
confirmed whether this was one of the
repatriation flights or not but we heard
from ben wallace defense secretary
earlier this morning and he confirmed
that the military side of kabul airport
was still operating and around 300
people did arrive back yesterday he said
around 700 afghans will be flown back
within the next 24 hours and their aim
is to get 12 to 1500 people back
every single day he said they're going
to do as much as possible to get people
back and it's something the prime
minister also said yesterday following
the cobra meeting that was held he said
that they will do as uh as they will try
to get people out as soon as we can
prime minister said that they've got the
resources to do this but if it's it's a
question of whether they can get this
done within the next few days
okay for now thanks aisha so 300 people
already back home according to the
defense secretary many many thousands
still need to be airlifted out of kabul
relying on the patience of the taliban
at the moment how long will that last
before they want their airport back more
on that takeover of afghanistan
throughout the show but first from today
people in england who are fully
vaccinated against coronavirus no longer
have to isolate if they come into
contact with someone who has tested
positive people will instead be advised
to take a pcr test but will not have to
self-isolate while they wait for the
result joined now
by a professor of social psychology at
the university of saint andrews and
independent sage member stephen reichert
although you are not speaking in that
capacity today i just should put that in
as a rider before you say anything it's
good to see you professor thanks for
joining us on the program uh so rules
change from today you won't have to
self-isolate if you've come into contact
with somebody who's had covid as long as
you are double vaccinated good idea
well first of all kate let me say that
um all the news from afghanistan does of
course make our problems seem well it
does put them in perspective somewhat
and it's difficult to talk about um
covet on a day like today but it is a
big change
i am
on the one hand concerned because it
does seem to be taking a big risk at a
time when infections are 30 times
what they were last year and despite all
the good work of the vaccine still
hospitalizations are 10 times what they
were last year to relax the rules
having said that i am a relative
optimist when there were the relaxations
on the 19th of july many people
including myself and i was wrong thought
that infections would skyrocket and the
reason why we're wrong in large part or
obviously there are many factors but one
of the reasons was the good sense of the
public the public continued to be
cautious continued to limit their
socialization continue to wear masks
into socially distance and the good
sense of the public in many ways kept us
safe
however there are two caveats to that
for the public to act with good sense
they need two things
the first is clear information and i
think it's really important to stress
again that while the vaccines are a
tremendously good thing they for
instance greatly reduced the extent to
which you get hospitalized if you get
infected they're not perfect so whereas
it used to be about 10 percent of people
with uh with got hospitalized it fell to
about two percent now it's back up to
about three percent but you can still be
hospitalized you can still get infected
you can still infect others so i think
it's really important to say to people
that having a pcr test is absolutely
vital it should be more than just do it
if you want to do it it's absolutely
vital and what's more i think it would
have made sense for to ask people to
self-isolate until they get the results
of that test but at the very least be
cautious be cautious around vulnerable
people don't go out too much don't go
into crowded spaces so we need really
clear information about how to keep
ourselves safe and how to keep others
safe and the second factor is this
see one of the problems of this whole
debate is that when we talk about
covered measures we often talk in terms
of restrictions as if all measures are
restrictions but many of the measures
are actually support for us they're
they're protections which allow us to do
the right thing support to allow us to
self-isolate and so on and the problem
is that if you now make it a choice to
people as to whether to take a test and
therefore to have to self-isolate if
you're positive people aren't going to
take that test if they can't afford to
be positive so we need to give people
more support so they can self-isolate if
they need to we need to give people the
support so they can make the right
choices to keep themselves safe and to
keep others safe do you think that
people will change their attitude their
approach now uh that they do they won't
have to self-isolate if they come into
contact with somebody who's had covert
do you think you know people will feel
freer
well
how people behave is absolutely critical
what all the analyses with all the
models tell you is
the effects of the changes in measures
are critically dependent upon our
behavior so let me take you give you one
very simple example before the pandemic
we interacted with about 12 different
people every week that fell to about
three
at the height of the pandemic earlier
this year it's now about four if
everybody suddenly went back to
pre-pandemic levels it would triple the
amount of interactions we have and
therefore vastly increase the
transmission and vastly increase the r
rate therefore making it very very
difficult to control the pandemic so our
behavior is absolutely critical and
that's why the messaging is so important
if you give the message to people that
once you're double vaccinated you are in
fact uh immune invulnerable that you
can't get infected you can't infect
others you're not going to be
hospitalized there is a very real danger
that we
increase
the extent to which we socialize and we
undermine the efforts against the
pandemic it's really important to have a
balanced message yes the vaccines are
great yes they've greatly reduced the
impact of the uh
of kovid but they haven't got rid of it
so we need to continue to be careful and
to be cautious and we need to support
people in acting carefully and
cautiously it's support that we need and
my fear is that in removing all measures
we remove the support necessary for
people to take responsible decisions
okay professor let's uh wait and see how
people behave it's good to talk to you
as always thanks for joining us
thank you thanks a lot
uh just looking at some more news
reaching us here at sky center i can
tell you that the latest we are hearing
from the reuters news agency is that
more than 90 of afghan state buildings
are now under taliban control that
according uh to uh fighters um at the
scene taliban fighters they've been
ordered we're told not to cause any
damage that according to taliban
officials in addition to that we're
being told that almost all major
checkpoints are under taliban control
and so all major checkpoints almost all
major checkpoints are under taliban
control now that could be a challenge
for some of these people who made their
way to the airport to try to flee the
country as soon as the taliban moved in
to the capital kabul about this time
yesterday but we are again hearing from
the taliban that everyone will be
allowed to return home from the airport
if they decide to stay and civilians
will not be harmed that is what a
taliban official is saying that people
who clamored to the airport to try and
get on these domestic aircraft none of
them are taking off at the moment if
they return home they will not be harmed
they will have to go through checkpoints
we're told in downtown kabul but they
will not be harmed that is what the
taliban is saying at this stage and
they've certainly been seizing
afghanistan at a speed that few could
have predicted much has been made of the
role of the united states with questions
being asked about both the decision to
withdraw troops and the speed of the
withdrawal but president biden has said
that he does not regret the move
joined now by uh sir peter westmacott
who was the uk's man in the united
states when combat operations in
afghanistan formerly ended in 2014.
hello to you thank you for joining us on
the programme this morning who would
have thought that we would have seen
kabul fall so speedily and and
potentially without bloodshed
i think you're right it is a surprise
that it fell quite so fast although
people i've spoken to who've been on the
ground i haven't been in afghanistan
myself for a few years but i do talk to
people who are there regularly
they all said the moment that the
deadline is set you will be amazed or
maybe you won't be amazed but the
taliban will take over the country in no
time because there just isn't the will
to fight and the problem of course is
not just that the americans in
particular and some of the other uh
forces like the british who've been
there uh holding a fort if you like were
going it is that they withdrawn the
intelligence the support the maintenance
the drones
um the different elements that would
have made it possible for the afghan
security forces to make a stand and i
think what's been a big surprise and
obviously disappointment is the afghan
security forces for those reasons and
forever just because they didn't
entirely believe that they were fighting
for a viable government collapsed so
quickly
lack of bloodshed well yes we are
hearing horrible stories of nasty things
happening anyone who's been wearing a
military uniform has been summarily
murdered on their doorstep and so on
there's been looting there have been
people pretending to be taliban who are
actually just rioters and thugs um
helping themselves to people's private
possessions um foreign embassies being
looted and so on but so far you're right
it looks like a minimal bloodshed and i
think it's very important that 60
different governments have issued that
statement
calling for order and saying you must
allow those who want to leave the
country to do so in good order
rory stewart told us on the program last
friday that what's happening is our
fault as in the united kingdom and and
the united kingdom's government um and
that we must deal with the fallout as a
result do you agree with his assessment
i think it was very surprising that both
the british defense secretary and the
chief of the defence staff nick carter
said you know back back at the time uh
that they were disappointed by the
american decision to set a date for
withdrawal we've had experience of this
whether it was in aden or in india
donkeys years ago and so on if you set a
date rather than conditions for
withdrawal of a foreign force for
whatever reason why it is there the
danger is that the people who want to
take over will just run down the top
and they will be ready to help
themselves so i think you know the
british authorities
did see the risk in what was going to
happen i don't think they were properly
consulted by their colleagues washington
and allies in washington which i i
regret um but i think it is on all of us
you know the british and were the second
most important foreign power in
afghanistan after the united states of
america it behooved all of us to try to
get this right i think people were taken
by surprise and we do now have a big
responsibility to try to ensure that the
collateral damage is minimal and not
just that our own people and our own
local employees are evacuated but those
people who've been working for
humanitarian organizations or
universities or for private security
companies defending our embassies and so
on that those people whose lives are in
danger must also be considered
legitimate for political asylum if they
want to leave the country as well
because i'm afraid evidence suggests
that we cannot rely on the word of the
taliban they've broken it so many times
in the past yeah i mean we
of course are responsible for our own
military operations uh i've heard from
the defense secretary this morning he's
saying that british forces returning to
afghanistan not on the cards anytime
soon what should our response be next
are we just washing our hands and
leaving the good people of afghanistan
to the taliban
well i hope we're not just going to wash
our hands first we've been there a lot
with the americans for 20 years the
immediate requirement as i say
is to try to deal with the humanitarian
issues right now those who need to leave
the country who've got the legitimate
reason to fear for their lives in the
safety of their families we've got to
help them
we've got to engage with those who are
now in charge to try to ensure that they
mean what they say hold them to those
commitments that there will not be
violence that they will not be looting
but there will be order that there will
not be recriminations and revenge taken
on people who they don't like the look
of
and we've also got to one way or another
engage with them and the international
organizations to try to ensure that some
of those gains in fact all the few gains
i should say in terms of treatment of
women and girls and going to the schools
and a degree of tolerance of ordinary
human rights are maintained that all
that isn't lost now that the taliban 20
years later are back in charge the risk
is that some of those people are not
under the control of the political uh
leaders who are talking to the americans
in doha and that they think that they've
run america and the rest of us out of
afghanistan which is not entirely forced
and i think it won which is not entirely
forth either so there will be a degree
of hubris there so we have to engage all
of us not just the british and americans
but other governments which have been
part of the coalition and international
organizations
to try to ensure that there is minimum
damage in the short term and then if we
can if the taliban will be prepared to
engage with the rest of the world try to
do something about the development and
the catastrophically fragile economy and
social fabric of support society so
peter sadly we're out of time thank you
for your expertise this morning as
always much appreciated
thank you thank you